Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, la question que j'ai reçue
vient de Joce, qui me dit :
« À qui appartiennent les maisons
des Autochtones dans les communautés? »
Joce, je sais que beaucoup de questions tournent
autour des maisons, d'appartenance, de pouvoir
posséder, louer, de pouvoir même avoir
la possibilité de vendre une maison.
Mais les maisons sur une réserve
– parce qu'il y a des communautés
qui sont des réserves, des communautés
qui ne le sont pas –, les maisons sur une
réserve, malheureusement,
sont liées à la Loi sur les Indiens.
C'est certain qu'on peut les louer.
On se les loue souvent entre membres
de communautés. Disons que quelqu'un va aux études
à l'extérieur, il va louer sa maison
à quelqu'un de la communauté
pour l'année ou pour les deux années
qui vont s'en venir.
Des fois, il y a des membres
de la communauté qui vont payer
pour faire bâtir une maison à leur goût, avec plus
de matériaux, mais la terre de réserve,
c'est-à-dire la terre qui est pour une utilisation fédérale,
est sur un territoire provincial.
Elle ne peut pas être vendue.
Donc ça va être souvent des espèces
de formes de location
qui sont exclusives
aux membres de la communauté.
Parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
qu'un non-Autochtone
ne peut pas venir vivre
sur une communauté. Il y a des maisons
qui sont allouées à des employés,
par exemple, qui eux peuvent venir vivre
pour un temps déterminé sur la communauté
pendant qu'ils y travaillent.
Mais ils ne peuvent pas acheter une maison
et c'est ce qui fait qu'on ne peut pas non plus
avoir d'hypothèque.
Parce que pour pouvoir hypothéquer,
il faut pouvoir saisir et pour pouvoir saisir,
c'est malheureusement impossible.
Bien, peut-être pas malheureusement,
mais c'est impossible sur une réserve de saisir
quelqu'un, parce qu'on est encore
sous la Loi sur les Indiens et on ne peut pas
saisir quelqu'un qui est mineur
aux yeux de la loi.
Il y a des communautés qui ne sont pas
des réserves, qui elles construisent les maisons,
suivent les mêmes règles de bâtiments
que dans des municipalités.
Elles peuvent faire ce qu'elles veulent
avec ces maisons-là,
mais ce ne sont pas des réserves.
Donc la maison en tant que telle
va souvent suivre le conseil de bande,
va être louée par le conseil de bande,
mais le conseil de bande va aussi
souvent respecter la passation familiale,
c'est-à-dire que la mère
ou la grand-mère va louer ou donner
la maison après son décès
à une de ses filles ou à son garçon.
Souvent ce sont des maisons qui vont
être même multigénérationnelles, multifamiliales.
Donc il peut y avoir une famille, deux familles,
trois familles qui vont vivre au sein de la maison.
Donc tu peux comprendre,
Joce, que la question
de l'habitation dans les communautés
est extrêmement difficile et extrêmement
coûteuse, aussi, parce que si ta communauté
est proche d'une ville ou en milieu
éloigné, faire construire,
ça change énormément les coûts
pour les mêmes matériaux.
Et le territoire est très limité aussi sur une réserve.
Donc ça fait souvent qu'on corde très serrées
les maisons. J'espère que ç'a pu y répondre,
mais tu comprendras que c'est une question
avec une très grande envergure
qui dépend aussi de chacune des communautés, comment elle décide de faire son plan d'urbanisme.
J'espère que j'ai répondu
à ta question,
j'espère que vous allez
nous en envoyer d'autres
et n'hésitez pas à partager ce vidéo.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine.